quand on regarde les conséquences très
désagréable qu'on pourrait avoir en
provenance du changement climatique
enfin ou d'un changement climatique non
maîtrisée il y en a une première qui est
pas assez à manger dans certaines
régions du monde il y en a une deuxième
qui est les dommages aux infrastructures
tout ce qui est vainement extrême
à l'occasion de la montée du niveau de
la mer ou à l'occasion d'autres
chose le lien avec la montagne peut ne
pas sembler évident les lois du niveau
de l'eau on est loin des problèmes
d'insuffisance alimentaire de l'egypte
donc tout ça ne concerne pas beaucoup
alors en fait un peu aussi quand même
parce qu'on a beau être à la montagne on
est dans un pays que s'il pays commence
à avoir des dérives politiques parce que
il ya trop de gens venant d'autres pays
qui rendent chez nous la montagne en
subira le contrecoup comme ailleurs est
par ailleurs en ce qui concerne les
dommages aux infrastructures s'ils sont
suffisants pour affaiblir l'économie du
pays
ça se ressentira aussi sur ce qui se
passe dans la montagne
il ya en plus des impacts climatiques
direct maintenant tout le monde commence
bien à se rendre compte que l'engagement
avec de plus en plus tard qu'il est de
plus en plus aléatoire en début de
saison ça c'est quand même un tout petit
sujet pour les gens qui vivent des
sports d'hiver
il y à des événements extrêmes dans la
basse montagne on va dire qu'ils peuvent
être de plus en plus violents des
épisodes cévenols ou des choses de cette
nature
donc il va aussi y avoir des impacts
directs qui peuvent travailler on peut
penser à autre chose je sais pas si
c'est déjà le cas dans la vallée de la
tarentaise
mais s'il se met à pleuvoir au lieu de
neiger en début d'hiver
à ce moment on peut avoir des coulées de
boue qu'on n'aurait pas si on avait de
la neige et donc des dommages aux routes
et c'est donc le alors tout ça en fait
n'empêche pas les gens respirent et
c'est à dire que brosse il ya un peu
moins de skieurs c'est un peu dommage
pour l'économie des stations de ski
c'était pas un drame dans l'absolu en
fait le drame dans l'absolu en ce qui
concerne le changement climatique
viendra des changements à large échelle
je le redis alors il ya il ya une
conséquence par exemple qui est très
très solide dans le cadre du changement
climatique c'est l'assèchement
progressif du pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen ça dans des pays à forte
démographie et qu'ils auront de moins en
moins les moyens économiques de
compenser par des importations de
nourriture
c'est une poudrière cette poudrière
rejaillira nécessairement sur les pays
européens les réfugiés syriens en sont
une première illustration
et ça par ricochet ça concernera la
motivation et les moyens économiques que
les gens auront pour venir aussi
il ya un deuxième sujet qui est
qu'aujourd'hui les grandes stations de
montagne typiquement la plagne ont une
clientèle qui est de plus en plus
international ce qui est logique
parce que à cause du deuxième volet de
la sphère qui est l'énergie le pouvoir
d'achat des français est en train de
s'effriter doucement et donc leur
capacité à venir au ce qui est en train
de s'effriter doucement aussi tant qu'on
a plein de pétrole c'est pas grave on
peut faire venir des touristes riche
venant d'ailleurs donc on peut faire
venir des riches pourquoi
anglais russes
casaque chinois bon peu importe dans un
monde dans lequel il sera un jour plus
difficile de se déplacer
c'est évident que ce genre de report
sera de plus en plus difficile c'est
très difficile d'illustrer ce genre de
conséquences par des événements de court
terme c'est très difficile de dire la
têt l'année où taux de remplissage a été
mauvais je sais que c'est à cause du
pétrole et je sais que c'est à cause du
changement climatique non il faut
regarder sur les séries longues mais sur
les séries longues malheureusement ces
deux tendances la sont plutôt à l'oeuvre
de manière adverse ce qui est plus
possible c'est d'appuyer sur un bouton
reset en disant ah on met tout à zéro
ça c'est totalement impossible ça
n'existe pas c'est un peu comme si vous
vous dites à 50 ans merde j'ai pas eu la
vie que j'aurais voulu
reset je me retrouve avec mes 20 ans
mais non c'est juste pas possible tant
pis donc je dis pas que il faut
regretter ce qu'on a fait pendant salle
il y juste
il ya des choses qui sont physiquement
impossible là c'est physiquement
impossible d'appuyer sur un bouton reset
et de dire bon remède climat dans lequel
dans l'est dans l'état dans lequel il
était en 1850 et on en parle plus c'est
pas possible de faire ça parce que je le
redis l'océan réagi à ce qu'on fait avec
des papes tant qu'ils sont les siècles
et les calottes polaires réagissait ce
qu'on fait avec des pâtes tant qu'ils
sont le millénaire
parti pour donc le niveau de l'eau de
l'océan par exemple va continuer à
monter mais à partir de maintenant
pendant des siècles où des milliers
d'années et aussi on est dans le haut de
la fourchette on va prendre 10 15 mètres
dos en plus donc le havre on finira par
être noyé boulogne et dunkerque union
paraître noyer nos rentes finira par
être noyé bordeaux finira par être noyé
doha la semaine prochaine mais et sarah
ce qui fait que ces villes là finiront
par lettre noyer c'est ce qui va se
passer dans le monde dans les 20 ou 30
ans qui viennent et donc le nombre de
centrales à charbon que la chine va
conserver dans les 20 ou 30 ans qui
viennent déterminant pour partie le fait
que bordeaux va être noyées ou pas comme
ça qu'il faut voir les choses
donc le ces phénomènes ont une inertie
encore une fois absolument considérable
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il faut
déjà se préoccuper malheureusement de ce
qu'on appelle l'adaptation mais
l'adaptation ça veut pas dire qu'on est
capable de garder les choses en l'état
ça veut dire qu'on se pose déjà la
question de savoir ce qu'on fera
éventuellement d'une partie des nantais
voilà ça veut dire qu'on se préoccupe
déjà aujourd'hui de savoir quelle
agriculture on aura de 20 quelle forme
quelle forêt on aura demain quel
implantations humaines en aura de vin
etc
alors pour en revenir à la question
politique dans les démocraties où les
pas de temps ces cinq ans les bonnes
années trois ans les moins bonnes années
et six mois la majeure partie du temps
on est totalement en dehors des clous
pour savoir gérer ce genre déchéance on
y arrive encore à peu près à l'échelle
de nos vies individuelles
quand on fait un enfant on sait qu'on en
prend pour 50 ans donc là on a quand
même des choses qu'on arrive à faire
avec des pas de temps un peu long mais
dès qu'on arrive dans l'organisation
collective dans les démocraties c'est du
court terme en permanence dans les
entreprises des cons à financiariser une
entreprise telle qu'elle est cotée en
bourse on raccourcit les horizons de
temps d'une manière absolument
spectaculaire donc on a un vrai sujet
dans l'économique et la financiarisation
de l'économie
non pas que je sois contre les
financiers par construction juste parce
que j'ai à dire la nature même de la
finance induit un raccourcissement des
échéances donc on est assez désarmés et
du reste je fais partie des gens qui
sont pas du tout persuadé que la
démocratie résistera aux problèmes que
je viens d'évoquer
c'est une vraie question les politiques
ne sont pas intéressés par les mauvaises
nouvelles donc c'était déjà vrai pour
les caisses de retraite qui est un petit
problème on regarde celui dont je suis
en train de parler
les politiques sont intéressés par des
solutions ils sont pas intéressés par
les problèmes
donc en gros nous dans la vie de tous
les jours on a toujours le réflexe de se
dire les politiques sont comme nous donc
ils sont comme des parents d'élèves à
qui on dit que leurs élèves ya un
problème où ils sont comme des gens qui
ont fait construire une maison et à qui
on dit là j'ai un problème avec la
construction de la maison si on leur
parle du problème
bon ça leur plaît pas mais ils vont
quand même réfléchi il prenne le
problème et ils se disent qu'est ce que
je peux faire une politique n'est pas
comme ça le politique
si vous lui soumettait à un problème il
n'en fera rien lui ce qui l'intéresse
c'est d'avoir une solution parce que le
politique
larbitre entre des gens qui lui
demandent des choses qui souvent sont
antagonistes donc temps que vous lui
demandez rien d'autre que de
s'intéresser à un problème il n'en fait
rien ce qu'il faut lui dire c'est je
veux qu'on monte le prix du carbone
alors ça ils ont fait quelque chose je
vous dis oui ou non il en fait quelque
chose
si vous lui dites je veux qu'on
développe les voitures électriques il en
fait quelque chose
oui ou non mais il en fait quelque chose
alors de temps en temps soit dit en
passant il en fait quelque chose dans un
sens qui aggrave le problème
je vais vous donner un exemple en france
qui ait le soutien au photovoltaïque à
l'électricité photovoltaïque
car en france vous soutenez
l'électricité photovoltaïque en
demandant aux contres enfin aux
consommateurs
c'est à dire aux contribuables c'est
pareil on a tous une facture électrique
directeur de l'ex-société de payer un
petit quelque chose pour qu'on puisse
donner de l'argent aux gens qu'ils
installent des panneaux
contrairement à ce qu'on pense on
n'évite pas d'émissions de co2 ça ne
change rien au climat parce que le
nucléaire fait pas de co2
l'hydroélectricité fait pas de co2 et
c'est tout ça fait 90% de l'électricité
française on ne crée pas d'emplois de
manière globale parce qu'on augmente les
importations de nucléaire demande très
peu d'importations le photovoltaïque en
demande beaucoup plus on ne développe
pas de filière industrielle nationale et
par contre on va mettre 30 milliards
d'euros là dedans qui aurait très bien
pu être utilisé pour faire autre chose
de beaucoup plus utile pour éviter
d'émettre du co2 et d'importer du
pétrole et du gaz par exemple isolé des
logements ou par exemple donner des
primes à la casse pour que les gens
achètent des plus petites voitures
donc on est en train de gaspiller de
l'argent sur des trucs qui servent à
rien
au lieu de le consacrer à des trucs qui
sert vraiment à quelque chose et bah ça
c'est parce que le politique a arbitré
armements dans un sens qui pour moi
n'est pas le bon qui était que les verts
sont venus en disant on veut pas de
nucléaire on veut du solaire et donc le
politique a dit oui en l'occurrence
c'était hollande parce que ça lui
permettait de rater trois pour cent aux
voix aux élections pardon donc le mélo
politique donc il ne se penche pas sur
le problème en faisant des règles de
trois et en réfléchissant un peu ils
arbitrent avec des gens qui viennent lui
faire des demandes donc le vrai sujet
c'est que les gens qui viennent faire
des demandes soient les plus nombreux du
côté de ce qu'on pourrait appeler le bon
sens et le moins nombreux possible du
côté de ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
fausses bonnes idées ou
trop d'égoïsme voilà et aujourd'hui
malheureusement c'est pas exactement
comme ça que ça se passe tout le temps
il ya des fois oui des fois non mais ça
se passe pas comme ça tout le temps